*Générique*
F: Salut à vous Mentalos de la chaîne du MentalVlog
il y a quelques temps je vous avais fait ma 3ème True Story
et j'avais dit que si on dépassé les 12 000 pouces en l'air on en refaisait une autre
et ça a été à une vitesse incroyable.
Je ne sais pas à combien je devrais mettre le quota pour la prochaine
parce que je n'ai pas tant d'histoire que ça dans ma vie non plus
Mais le fait est que promesse annoncée, promesse tenue
Et aujourd'hui je suis avec Philippe Roche
C'est la 4ème fois que tu viens sur la chaîne
P: Ouais ouais
F: Normal c'est un pote donc dés qu'il passe, quasiment, on fait une vidéo
P: 4?
F: 3, 4? 4
P: Je ne suis pas mentaliste, je peux pas dire
F: 3 ou 4 je sais plus. En tout cas celle que je préfère c'est celle où tu m'apprends à faire des imitations
je vous la mets en fiche juste ici
regardez la après elle est rigolote
donc aujourd'hui Philippe est passé à la maison, on vient d'aller manger ensemble
et je lui ai dis "Tiens et on a pas une histoire marrante à raconter"
déjà que tu étais dans la dernière True Story
tu l'as pas regardé? Dans l'avant dernière true story
P: Dans l'avant dernière
F: C'est quand on était en Ukraine
P: Ouh... Ah les gens ont vu
*rires*
F: Tu sais pas quel souvenir j'ai raconté, tu regarderas
P: c'est ça qui est.. qui fait peur
F: Tu as qu'à regarder la chaîne aussi, mon... mes meilleurs amis ne regardent pas la chaîne
P: Mais non c'est faux, on est, on est constamment avec toi
*rires*
P: C'est juste que... bon on peut pas non plus te dire qu'on est tout le temps avec toi
tu comprends il faut ...
F: Vous pouvez vous référer aux vidéos sur les mensonges pour voir ce qu'il est en train d'essayer de me faire *rire*
Moi, j'avais un souvenir particulier, je t'ai demandé l'autorisation de le raconter. N'est ce pas?
P: Bé... je te... le donne
F: Et au début très franchement tu m'as dit direct "Non"
P: Ouais
*Rires de Fabien*
P: Non mais parce qu'à un moment donné, c'est sûr, ça peut créer une image un peu... fausse.
du personnage.
F: Oui c'est vrai, c'est vrai. C'est arrivé 5 fois
P: Oui voilà
à peine.
F: Non c'est arrivé une seule fois
Alors il y a quelques années, je sais pas  combien de temps ça fait? 4ans? 5ans?
P: Ouais ouais 5 ans
F: 4-5 ans j'avais, tu m'arrêtes quand je dis des bêtises, ça se peut
P: Ok
F: J'avais une date sur Avignon
C'était à Avignon?
P: Lyon
Non, oui c'était à Avignon
*rires*
P: [en rigolant] C'était bien Avignon
F: C'était à Avignon c'était une exceptionnelle je crois que je faisais là bas
et après on a un peu traîné à rentrer puisqu'on est allés chez ton cousin
P: Oui et il était déjà une heure très avancée de la matinée
F: Ouais
P: Il était 4h - 5h et tu prenais un train vers 6h30
F: En tout cas c'était avant 7h.
Et ce train était très important parce que j'avais un rendez vous derrière à Paris
que je ne pouvais pas rater.
P: Un contrat
F: Ah non même encore pire que ça
Exactement ouais j'avais
P: Un contrat
*rires*
F: J'avais un contrat
P: On peut le dire
F: Fallait que je repasse par Paris pour repartir sur le contrat. Exact
P: A Angers
Tout simplement, en fait, on se dit on va pas dormir, ça sert à rien
F: C'est plus simple sinon on risque de se foirer
P: Voilà, on va pas se réveiller
et donc je connais la région comme ma poche
F: Ooooooh
P: donc à partir de ce moment là, on a une heure
F: [prenant accent du Sud] Je connais tous les chemins de mon pays
P: et le chemin fait à peu près 25 minutes
donc en bon sudiste
un quart d'heure c'est bon
F: Moi je me fis à lui
c'est co-pilote quoi... tu vois c'est...
P: Donc euh pour le train à 6h30 on peut partir à 6h
on est... large
*rire* parce que je connais des chemins de campagnes
mais bon... je les connait de jour et d'autres de nuit
et... ce qui fait qu'à un moment donné on est sérieusement en retard
et...
F: Le drame commence je vous le dis direct, le drame commence
P: Le drame commence parce que j'arrive dans un axe qui est sûr et cet axe, il était en travaux
et donc si je me plante de voie
je nous mets 10km dans la vue
et il nous reste 12minutes avant l'arrivée de ton train
F: Et ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'il commence à être très fatigué
mais c'est pas tant que tu es picolé d'ailleurs parce que tu n'avais pas tant pic.. enfin en tout cas
on avait picolé il était genre 23h donc là, à 6h du matin tu avais désoulé
P: Oui
F: Mais c'est que tu es fatigué. Il est papa en plus il se lève tôt le matin etc...
[Philippe éclate de rire]
P: Tout le dossier. Oui parce que... *rires*
ça j'adore. N'oublions pas qu'il est papa donc il picole pas, il est très bien
F: Et je connais Philippe quand il est comme ça, qu'il commence à perdre patience
et je vois quand même que derrière le Put*** de travaux de m**de bla bla bla
moi je dis rien
un peu par lâcheté principalement
*rires*
P: Non mais c'est quand même très agaçant d'arriver dans une ville
que tu connais bien
et qu'ils mettent des travaux comme ça sans déviation.
Il y avait pas marqué déviation
F: Surtout que depuis 24h il dit:
"Et je connais la ville comme ma poche mon pote
P: Je te préviens
F: C'est ce que je vois
P: En fait on est parti vers Nîmes au lieu de partir vers Avignon
concrètement c'est ce qu'il s'est passé
C'est exactement ça ce qu'il s'est passé
F: De quoi? c'est à dire?
P: Ben arrivé à Avignon je te fais prendre la direction il y avait 2 directions à prendre
il y avait pas de déviation donc je prends celle où il y a les travaux
et à partir de ce moment là je vais direction Nîmes
mais moi je ne te le dis pas
parce que
tout ce que tu me dis c'est
je te demande
toujours le timing
F: Oui
P: Combien de temps?
combien de temps?
ça va le faire , ça va le faire, ça va le faire
et donc je me souviens qu'il y a un petit passage qui me permettrait de faire un demi tour sous le pont
le pont de l'Europe
et... ce passage... avant les travaux était praticable
en...
dans le bon sens du terme
F: Il me dit: "Il y a pas de problème tu va voir je connais un autre chemin"
et il trace des petites rues.
Moi je commence
gentiment à sortir mon portable pour chercher google map et essayer de  voir en temps réel
si c'est les bonnes directions ou pas
et toi tu fais "roh je reconnais pas"
je m'en souvient tu disais: "Put*** je reconnais pas, je reconnais rien"
P: Non mais ils ont vraiment changé les panneaux
sauf qu'à un moment donné à cette endroit là je savais que je pouvais tourner à droite
donc machinalement je tourne à droite
F: Et là il tourne à droite alors je ralenti un peu le...
cette story, puisque que
effectivement on est à un endroit où on ne reconnait pas,
ou il y a les panneaux de changer j'en sais rien moi tout ce que je vois ce que...
qu'on est sur une route et qu'il tourne à droite
et, moi je prends conscience de quelques choses je vous le dit juste après
et là
Philippe est très stressé parce qu'il ne veut pas que je rate le train
un peu énervé de tout ce qu'il se passe
et très fatigué parce qu'il est 6h et quelque du matin
et mon train et dans quelques minutes
et donc je calme un peu le jeu et je fais:
[Voix calme] "Philippe est ce que tu peux t'arrêter s'il te plait" mais vraiment avec cette voix là quoi
et il me fait "ah ben on a pas le temps et tout"
Je fais : "Non vraiment arrête toi je te dis un truc, arrête toi une seconde"
[P] "Ah pas le temps
Je lui fait "S'il te plait, sérieusement, mon pote juste voilà sur le bas côté"
et tu t'arrêtes
P: Je me suis arrêté
F: [imitant Philippe] "Ah put*** qu'est qu'il y a on est déjà à la bourre"
Je fais "Alors il se passe
qu'on est en train de rentrer sur l'autoroute à contre sens"
et ce que j'avais repéré c'est que quand tu as tourné à droite
je voyais tout les panneaux qui nous faisait dos. Tu sais
P: Alors c'était une petite autoroute
*rires*
P: On appelle ça une voie rapide mais, mais *rires*
F: Du coup ça va *ri*
P: Ben oui puis surtout que, bon à un moment donné, ils ont changé tout les panneaux de sens, ça voulait rien dire
je suis passé 100 fois dans ma jeunesse sur ce panneau
normalement tu passes sous le pont
et bien là on passe pas sous le pont, on arrive sur une voie rapide bon
F: Tu m'étonnes qu'ils ont changé les panneaux de sens
on ne les voyait pas puisqu'ils étaient dos à nous
puisqu'on allait dans le mauvais sens
*rires*
Tu sais c'est ce qu'on appelle la voie de décélération, en fait quand tu sors de la VOIE rapide
Bon après peut être que tu connais mieux que moi
que tu sais qu'il y a personnes à cette heure ci
et que c'est plus rapide de la prendre en contre sens
P: Bon écoutes 5 ans plus tard je peux te le dire
Bonne nouvelle je vais bientôt passer mon permis
*rires*
P: Donc c'est plutôt cool
Je passais souvent dans ce coin là
en scooter
Du coup, pour moi je connaissais tout par coeur
mais non.
F: Ben c'est le jour où j'ai
P: Bon après il y a 2 ponts, le pont d'Avignon et le pont de l'Europe
F: Ah put*** ta gu**le
*rires*
F: Moi j'ai cru que j'allais mourir, l'autre il me dit ça
En vrai ce jour là j'ai compris comment ça arrivait qu'ils y ai des personnes qui se retrouvent en sens inverse sur l'autoroute
P: Enfin, généralement ils ont 80 ans passé
F: Ah ouais, ben toi tu avais 80 grammes passé
*rires*
comme quoi il y a toujours une histoire de 80 quelque part
A contre sens en marche arrière du coup on était dans le bon sens *ri*
P: Ahahah non mais la finalité le suspens les gens veulent savoir
F: Est ce que j'ai eu mon train ou pas?
Après tu as fait demi tour, tu as tracé, tu as tracé et après il faut savoir qu'ensuite
comme il m'avait fait un peu peur
je lui mentais
c'est à dire que mon train était dans 4 minutes
il me disait: "Et là il est dans combien de temps ton train?
Je disais "dans 8 minutes
tout va bien
on est large"
et en fait je préférais te mentir sur le timing et
P: Ouais ouais t'inquiète Fabien on va l'avoir
je me souviens d'avoir dis ça, Fabien on va l'avoir
F: ouais et moi je savais que j'avais déjà doublé le temps mais je préférais ça
et au final put*** je l'ai eu de...
j'ai sauté dedans
P: Oui
F: J'ai sauté dans le train
P: Oui clairement
clairement
F: Je suis rentré dans le train et les portes elles ont fait pffff direct
P: Et on a eu le temps de se dire au revoir
et j'ai fini, ou j'ai commencé ma nuit dans la voiture j'ai plus pu bougé après il faut être honnête
F: C'est vrai? avant de repartir?
P: Ouais ouais j'ai dit tiens je me prends 5 minutes et il s'est bien passé 5h
*rires*
P: Je me suis réveillé cramer par le soleil
F: Voici la True Story
du jour
avec Philippe
et comme tu étais déjà apparu dans la True Story de l'Ukraine
vous vous rendez compte que j'ai pleins d'histoires avec ce mec
et celle ci n'était pas la plus valorisante pour toi
P: Ah et puis j'avais  20 ans
F: Mais c'était il y a 4 ans
P: 4-5 ans 25
F: Pourquoi on vous raconte cette histoire parce que comme quoi ça peut arriver
sans faire gaffe et que c'est intéressant quand
qu'en ne t'agressant pas, parce que j'ai vu le mec qui est dans un schéma de...
je suis à la bourre, faut que je le ramène et
qu'il ne comprends pas pourquoi je veux qu'il s'arrête
tu vois le truc
P: Oui, enfin bon
en même temps on aurait peut être pu partir un poil plus tôt
F: Et oui, ben moi je te suivais
P: Ouais je connaissais bien la région
F: [prenant accent du Sud] Je connais tout les chemins de mon pays
Merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère que ça, ça vous a plu
Je vous recommande, vivement, de regarder au moins la dernière vidéo qu'on a faite avec Philippe
je vous avais mis la fiche là haut
je vous mets aussi le lien dans la description
Philippe est un imitateur, performer vocale. Je ne sais pas pourquoi je tapote comme ça
comme si on était des méga potes mais
alors que
P: Ça fait 5 ans qu'on s'est pas vu
F: Ça fait 5 ans... ah oui *ri*
N'hésitez pas à regarder les vidéos qu'on avait fait ensemble
ou à découvrir la chaîne de Philippe d'ailleurs je vous la mets aussi dans la description
Merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo et je vous dis
Abonnez vous à la chaîne si c'est pas déjà fait
et rendez vous demain 17h
Tchao!
P: Pour ma décharge, je suis né dans le Vaucluse
mais j'ai pas habité dans le Vaucluse
je suis Parisien
et, sauf que j'ai vécu 4 ans,
allez 4 ans de mon adolescence ce qui fait que je parcourais toute ces terres là
et en fait c'était le parisien qui faisait croire qu'il connaissait le sud quoi
et j'ai pas osé lui dire
c'est pour ça que j'ai pris cette... petite voie rapide
dans le mauvais sens